quelles sont leurs chances de voir les
musées rouvrir et bien on va voir ça
tout de suite avec notre reporter solène
gaudin cela une bonjour alors
l'interrogation est ce que les musées
pourrait ré ouvrir prochainement et bien
une pièce c'est en tout cas ce
qu'espèrent les directeurs de musées il
espère d'ailleurs rouvrir pendant les
vacances scolaires d'hiver qui ont
débuté vendredi dernier pour certaines
régions alors en tout on compte plus de
1200 musées en france
tous ont fermé leurs portes pour la
deuxième fois le 30 octobre dernier et
depuis leurs directeurs et leurs
employés se sont mobilisés à travers des
manifestations des tribunes ou encore
des pétitions je vous propose de les
écouter pour une heure un jour une
semaine ou un mois
laissez-nous entre ouvrir nos portes
même si nous devions les refermer en cas
de nouveau confinement dire qu'une
boutique de lingerie c'est essentiel
mais qu un musée public c'est non
essentiels on marche sur la tête
le musée a une fonction essentielle et
pour mettre toutes les chances de leur
côté ses directeurs de musées
apporteront des propositions concrètes
lors de cette réunion
voyez par exemple ce que propose le le
palais de tokyo à paris le palais de
tokyo ces vingt-deux mille mètres carrés
même avec une jauge restrictive ça
permet d'accueillir pas mal de gens même
temps ça permet vraiment des promenades
masqué sans le moindre risque
nous sommes prêts à rouvrir aussi vite
qu'on nous a demandé de fermer il y a
trois mois on est prêt à faire du stop
and go s'il le faut pour s'adapter à
l'évolution des vague de la pandémie
le stop and go c'est à dire ouvrir puis
refermer si la situation sanitaire le
nécessitent ou encore ouvrir par
intermittence seulement le week end ou
un jour sur deux ou bien uniquement pour
les sorties scolaires
mais alors pourquoi seul m les musées et
pas les autres établissements culturels
et bien le musée met en avant que les
visiteurs peuvent circuler dans ces
établissements ce qui est impossible par
exemple dans une salle de cinéma
autre argument l'espace dans leur
structure qui permet de mettre en place
la distanciation social impossible à
mettre en place dans les salles de
spectacle les directeurs de musées
s'appuie aussi sur l'exemple de pays
16 ans l'espagne ou l'italie deux pays
fortement impacté par la crise sanitaire
qui ont réouvert leurs musées depuis
juillet déjà en espagne et depuis le 1er
février pour l'italie un argument qui a
été en revanche balayé il y a quelques
semaines par roselyne bachelot écoutez
la fermeture des lieux culturels en
europe
il y à quelques exemples de pays qui
font des ouvertures mais cette fermeture
elle est générale elle est générale en
grande-bretagne et général en allemagne
général ou pays d'olmes
elle est générale en europe donc et il
faut bien comprendre que devant la
gravité de cette crise sanitaire des
décisions lourdes sont prises
vous voulez une date de réouverture
ferme je ne peux pas vous la donner
aujourd'hui je serai totalement
irresponsable de vous donner une telle
date
aujourd'hui et les musées ont-ils reçu
un soutien politique cela n'a alors oui
les jets plusieurs élus se sont exprimés
mais toujours avec prudence
dernier en date françois bayrou s'était
dit hier je vous propose de l'écouter
je pense qu'on peut rouvrir les musées
avec toute la prudence nécessaire à
l'entrée en vérifiant que les 2 mètres
entre les visiteurs sont respectés alors
de son côté jean castex a bien donné un
espoir au musée lors de son allocution
jeudi dernier le premier ministre
affirmait que les espaces dits circulant
rouvrirait avant les salles de cinéma et
les salles de spectacle mais pour le
moment aucune date n'a été fixée
et selon les informations du jdd hier le
ministère de la culture juge la
situation sanitaire catastrophique
cette réunion aujourd'hui offrent donc
pour le moment peu d'espoir pour les
musées merci beaucoup cela n pour toutes
ces précisions on suivra bien évidemment
cette visioconférence cet après midi sur
rt france